Captain Jeff RANDALL: Imagine a place that is
very white. And all you see around you is ice.
All you see is vastness. All you see is
great expanses of nothing. The ice never
seems to end. It goes on forever. It's an
area of immense beauty or immense loneliness.
That is the region that is the Arctic.
Gabrielle SIERRA:
The Arctic. It sits at the top of the globe, is
covered in snow and sea ice and has days without
sunlight. We think of it in terms of extremes
- harsh, cold, barren. But the Arctic is also
home to 4 million people, endangered species and
a wealth of minerals and oil buried in the earth.
For centuries it was inaccessible to anyone but
the most daring explorers and scientists. But now,
as climate change takes its toll, the ice
is melting fast, new routes are opening,
and the world could be facing new competition
over Arctic riches. To complicate matters,
no single country actually owns the place. The
U.S. has a portion through Alaska. Russia has a
large sector of Arctic territory in the far North,
and six other countries have territories of their
own. And in the middle is a vast section that
belongs to everyone, and no one. I’m Gabrielle
Sierra and this is Why It Matters. Today, the
Arctic, where diplomatic relations are teetering
on thin ice.
Esther BRIMMER:
The Arctic, you should think of as a
frozen ocean surrounded by land. So
they're basically two big land masses.
SIERRA: This is Esther Brimmer, Senior Fellow
in Global Governance here at the Council. She
is a former Assistant Secretary of State for
International Organization Affairs, which means
she worked with a lot of global institutions on a
lot of global issues, including the Arctic.
BRIMMER: One is the Eurasian landmass,
including Russia and the Nordic countries, and
the North American portion, which includes the
United States state of Alaska and Canada. The
North American side has coastal plains in parts
of Alaska. It has a series of islands in Canada.
And about 25,000 miles worth of coastline is in
Russia. The US has a significant amount of about
6,000 miles of coastline. So these are big spaces,
but they're also very different spaces.
SIERRA: What is it like operating
in Arctic extremes?
RANDALL: One, it's cold. Two,
there's lots of ice, especially when you get up
into the ice cap regions, there's a beauty that
exists there like no other place on Earth.
SIERRA: This is Captain Jeff Randall. He’s
the visiting military fellow for the U.S. Coast
Guard at the Council. Jeff has spent a great deal
of time in the Arctic, leading two Coast Guard
cutters and conducting fisheries law enforcement
throughout the Pacific Arctic region.
RANDALL: And knowing the whole time that you're
operating up there that you're very alone. If
you're a ship, there's not a lot of gas stations.
If there's a person, there's not a lot of grocery
stores. If you're trying to operate there,
you have to think about your ability to sustain.
You have to basically take everything with you
that you need to operate there. So you'd
have to stuff all that into your backpack,
so to speak, and carry that up there
with you, because at the same token,
if you get in trouble there, if your car
breaks down, or in this case your ship,
you need to be prepared to stay there for
a while or sustain yourself until rescue
can come. It's a very challenging region to
operate in because you're so far from anything,
so far from anywhere.
SIERRA:
So does anyone own the Arctic?
BRIMMER: That's a very interesting
question because you can think of the Arctic
as having sort of two parts. There's the part
of the Arctic that is ocean, as we discussed,
that in a sense is owned by everybody as what
was commonly called ‘common heritage of
mankind.’ That means that it's governed
by the United Nations Convention on the
Law of the Sea, which pertains to the
rules of the open ocean.
SIERRA: Arg the law of the sea!
It may sound made up or like something pirates
adhere to, but it is in fact a very real treaty.
Basically, countries governing a shared region
like space or the world’s oceans gets pretty
tricky. Regions often have conflicting
economic interests and claims. The Law
of the Sea prescribes a framework for when
and how countries can establish rights at
sea - this includes specific rules for marking
maritime boundaries, extracting resources,
and navigating through foreign territory. It’s
important to note that the United States has
never ratified the convention, though it does
abide by the norms it establishes. While the Law
of the Sea is real, there is a lot of ambiguity
when it comes to what countries can and can’t do
in open water. Things can get choppy!
BRIMMER: We have eight countries that have
territory in the Arctic region. Those include
Canada, Denmark, Finland, Iceland, Norway,
the Russian Federation, Sweden, and of course
the United States. I should note that the
Kingdom of Denmark has territory in this area
because of its relationship with Greenland.
An important new factor is that China has become
much more active in the Arctic. China is not
technically an Arctic country. However, China
has described itself as a near-Arctic nation
because the very northern parts of Manchuria
are just below the Arctic Circle.
SIERRA: China has been quite busy in the
Arctic lately, doubling its investment in
Arctic initiatives over the past decade, with a
focus on mineral extraction, scientific research,
and military research. President Xi Jinping has
expressed ambitions to become a “polar great
power,” and he recently integrated the development
of a ‘Polar Silk Road’ into China’s existing
Belt and Road initiative. China’s presence
could change dynamics in the Arctic. After all,
most Arctic nations are allies through NATO, and
tensions between Russia and NATO have been running
high since the invasion of Ukraine.
BRIMMER:
Of the eight Arctic nations, five of them
have coastline directly on the Arctic Ocean.
For those countries, they have, as all countries
do, 12 nautical miles of territorial sea and then
200 miles of exclusive economic zone. So
when we think about who owns the Arctic,
there is the part that's since held as ‘common
heritage of mankind,’ the ocean in the middle,
and the territorial waters around it, and then
different nations have different rules about who
owns land within their own countries, but we can
think about it both as common heritage surrounded
by territorial waters and territorial land.
SIERRA: While each state has its own territory,
under the international Convention of the Law of
the Sea, foreign vessels are allowed to travel
peacefully through those areas. The law also bans
weapons testing, spying, arbitrarily claiming new
territory, and a number of other things. It also
protects resources in coastal territories from
foreign extraction, bolstering states’ authority
over their zones of influence. The Law of Sea
provides structure to Arctic disputes, but there’s
still a lot of gray area when it comes to shared
waters. It’s easier to conduct business in claimed
territory. And that is why Arctic countries spend
a lot of time remapping their waters, in the
hope that they can extend their claims.
RANDALL: A lot of the work that's going on up
there right now is to figure out the limits of
those continental shelves, to figure out
the limit of the claims, because there is
the potential for resources on the seabed or under
the sea floor, and potentially fisheries resources
that countries could lay claim to.
SIERRA: So what is going on up there
now? Why are we talking about it?
BRIMMER: The Arctic region brings together
so many important trends at the same time.
The first is that significant climate change
is happening in the Arctic region.
PBS: Warming in the Arctic is having dramatic
impacts now, with worse yet to come.
PBS: News for wildlife, native communities
and global sea level rise is not good.
Sky News: A fragile ecosystem is being lost,
and the effects are reverberating
around the whole planet.
BRIMMER: Now, every day we pick up the headlines
and we hear about climate change. That includes
rapid temperature change, and we're seeing that
in the Arctic. The Arctic may be warming up at
least twice as fast as the rest of the globe,
maybe even three times as fast according to
some experts. Indeed, the National Oceanographic
and Atmospheric Administration known as NOAA says
that the past seven years are collectively the
warmest on record. What we're seeing here is
that because of the warming of the Arctic region,
you're having melting of the polar ice cap. It is
conceivable that part of the Arctic Ocean could
be navigable in the near term. Some people think
2050, some people 2040, some people think 2030.
Well, that means you might be able to sail ships
through an area that used to be ice. Therefore, we
see a variety of economic interests because of the
environmental change that say perhaps we have
access to oil and gas, perhaps we can cut down
the time of shipping between Europe and Asia.
SIERRA: Ships that currently navigate through the
Suez or Panama canals could cut their
shipping distances by up to half by
traveling through the Arctic, which would
mean huge savings in fuel over time.
WION: Typically, a ship from Rotterdam to Japan
would use the Suez Canal and take thirty days.
Once the Arctic ice melts, the new routes
emerge. The distance is going to shrink.
CNBC: Arctic sea routes are potentially
much more useful for avoiding the kind
of bottlenecks that one would see in
either the Panama or Suez Canal.
CNBC: It’s really a question of
saving shipping costs, saving time,
versus that lack of predictability.
BRIMMER: Let's take a moment and look at the two
major routes within the Arctic space. One is the
Northern Sea Route, which runs through Russian
waters, as well as international waters. You can
think of the Northern Sea Route as one of the
navigational routes that goes along the Eurasian
coast within the Arctic region. The other major
route includes the Northwest Passage and goes
by the North American side of the Arctic.
SIERRA: The Northern Sea Route, running
along the Russian Arctic coast, services
most major Arctic ports and the rivers of
Siberia. It’s a part of what’s known as
the Northeast passage. The Northwest Passage,
running up the other side, connects Alaska to
Greenland and passes through several contested
waterways. When it was first traversed in 1903,
the Northwest Passage took three years to cross.
Today, it takes about 24 days. But these areas
can also be very dangerous. Ships can face deadly
rogue waves and surging storms as they cross,
and if something goes wrong, there often aren’t
any nearby ports to mount a rescue from.
BRIMMER: Operating and navigating in the Arctic
is always challenging and 20 years from now,
there could still be significant hazards of pieces
of ice making it a challenging place in which to
navigate. That said, the warming of the Arctic
does open up possibilities of greater exploration
for oil, gas, and minerals. And so there are
companies and countries that are interested
in greater investment in these areas.
SIERRA: Right now, the Arctic supplies about
10% of the world’s oil and a quarter of
its natural gas. And scientists predict
that there is much more buried under the ice.
BRIMMER: Production from these areas are extremely
important. We note that for Russia, which
is now currently under sanctions because of
its invasion of Ukraine, that the Arctic oil
that it produces is going to India and China,
which means it's still earning income from
that because it's able to get its oil out of
the Arctic region to other suppliers now that
they're no longer delivering to Europe.
SIERRA: The U.S.-held Arctic is also energy
rich. In fact, the Biden Administration recently
approved a new drilling project called Willow in
the Alaskan Arctic. Experts say it could reap over
600 million barrels of crude oil over the next
thirty years. For people living in Arctic states,
these investments can be polarizing -
pitting local economic interests against
cultural and environmental priorities.
But this is only the most recent example
in a long history of Arctic extraction.
BRIMMER: There are also enormous effects just of
the environmental interest. It has direct impact
on the livelihoods of people, it has direct impact
on food sources for people, it has direct impact
on a large number of animals who live in the area,
including polar bears, whales, and others. Some
of the megafauna that people are familiar with,
that there could be fundamental changes in
the habitats for marine mammals as well.
There could be important changes in fishing. Fish
and fish stocks, and the benefits of the sea are
huge food sources. If water temperature changes,
the movement of fish and other foods would also
change. In addition to that, you have people whose
homes, and livelihoods, and culture, would be lost
as communities literally slip into the sea.
SIERRA: There are nearly half a million indigenous
people living in the Arctic circle, spanning more
than 40 different ethnic groups. Fishing, hunting,
and whaling are the main ways these communities
have survived in this harsh region for over
15,000 years. But climate change and commercial
ventures have led to a shift in migration
patterns, impacting native food sources. And given
many native communities live without access to
running water or a functioning sewer system, many
groups may soon be forced to relocate. Alongside
Arctic natives are 3.5 million non-indigenous
hunters, herders, and city locals, who also
rely on the region to raise their families, farm,
and run businesses. These two groups often find
themselves at the mercy of more powerful forces -
a changing climate, and a group of large nations
vying to control the region’s future.
BRIMMER: As we said earlier, there are about
4 million people living in the Arctic. About 2
million of them are in Russia, and about 500,000
are Indigenous people. Also, from the US
perspective, have to recognize that these
environmental challenges are also highlighting
already existing challenges faced by Alaska
native communities. There are at least 31
Alaska native communities that do not have
reliable running water in their homes. 60% of
Alaska native communities have been described as
environmentally threatened by climate change. And
finally, working in Alaska is challenging. Only
about 20% of the State of Alaska is accessible by
roads. Therefore, boats and aircraft are crucial
for transportation. So that this important climate
change is happening in an area that is complex,
very large, and already difficult to work in,
making the effort more challenging, and the need
for cooperation, all that more important.
SIERRA: But instead of cooperation, as the ice
continues to melt, the race for precious
resources is going to heat up competition
even further in the open Arctic. And because the
stakeholders are either NATO-aligned countries,
or NATO rivals, the chances for that economic
competition to spill over into military tension
has many analysts concerned. Already, Norway
and Russia are butting heads over control
of the Norwegian Svalbard islands in the Arctic
Circle. Russia is asserting that a historical
right to mine there is being blocked by Ukraine
War-related sanctions, and Moscow is threatening
“retaliatory measures” if Norway doesn’t let
them resume their operations in the region.
Situations like this can get tense - fast.
SIERRA: And what about the military side
of things? Is there a history of U.S.
military presence in the arctic?
RANDALL: If you think about post-World War
II, we entered into a period of a Cold War,
where you basically had Russia and the US
at odds with each other. During that time,
and because of World War II, where the
Japanese had actually invaded the Aleutians,
you saw a buildup of military presence
through early warning sites, through basing,
through other infrastructure in the Arctic region.
As the Cold War progressed, and as we ended up
coming out of the Cold War in the early '90s, we
let a lot of that infrastructure atrophy. Yes,
we still have some early detection, we still have
some presence up there, but some of the basing
and some of the infrastructure we let atrophy
over time. Then, as you saw Russia begin to
militarize their Arctic, we began rethinking about
our operations, our ability to sustain operations,
and our ability to project military power from
the Arctic region. And so, that's brought us back
to an era where we're starting to think about
infrastructure investments, thinking about our
operations, and thinking about what investments
we need to make in the regions to ensure that we
can protect our sovereignty and project power, if
needed, if there were to be conflict across the
Bering Strait or other areas in the region.
SIERRA: As it stands, Russia is the dominant power
in the Arctic, exceeding NATO’s number of military
bases by a third. And in the past two years,
Russia has upgraded nearly a dozen Soviet-era air
strips at its Northernmost base and spent millions
on artillery improvements for its Northern Fleet
- the largest icebreaker armada in the world.
And these are just some of the moves that have
made other Arctic nations wary when it comes to
Russia’s ambitions for the region.
SIERRA:
Let's talk about national security. What are we
worried about when we look at the Arctic?
BRIMMER: The Arctic poses several challenges for
national security. For one, half of the entire
coastline in the United States is in Alaska.
So first and foremost, you have just the normal
defense of the United States borders. In addition,
the United States is aware, of course,
that Russia has been upgrading its military
installations in the region, and it has
been reinvesting in its infrastructure.
We saw after the end of the Cold War a reduction
in tensions, a greater spirit of cooperation, of
which the Arctic Council is a good example.
SIERRA: The Arctic Council is an international
forum that includes representatives from
all 8 arctic nations, as well as from local
communities. Formed in 1996, the Arctic Council
brought together Russia and its former Cold War
adversaries in the hope that they could cooperate
to manage a region that was important to all of
them. For years the Arctic Council was a symbol of
fruitful cooperation between rivals, but now the
organization’s fate is unclear. Russia is chairing
the council for the next two years and very little
cooperation is expected in the near term.
SIERRA: Okay. So where do you see us going as
a nation in the Arctic?
RANDALL: I think what you're
going to see is an area where we're going to
have to make some investment. I think you're
going to have to make some investment
not only in our ability to operate up
there through icebreaking capability in
ships. I think you're going to see some
need for investment up there to make sure
you have the ability to operate in a more
continuous and sustained basis. I think
you're going to see probably some more
military exercises up there, and not necessarily
as a counter to what we see in Russia, but to show
that we can operate up there and make sure that
we are making the right investments to ensure our
ability to operate in the region as needed.
BRIMMER: There's several different ways of being
present in the Arctic. One of them is physical
presence. So for example, the Russian Federation,
because it has the longest coastline within the
Arctic region, has an important physical presence
in the Arctic by virtue of its own geography.
The Nordic states, again, because they have
long coastlines have an important presence in
the Arctic, but there are other ways of being
present in the Arctic. And one of them is an
area which is undergoing change at the moment.
Both Finland and Sweden have applied to join
NATO. This would mean if they're approved by
all the NATO states, that all of the members of
the Arctic region, except for Russia, would be
NATO members. So being part of an alliance is also
part of being present in the Arctic. In a sense,
NATO becomes more present in the Arctic.
SIERRA: How much energy should we be focusing
on the Arctic at this point?
RANDALL: Well, I would tell you it's a
priority amongst priorities. And anytime you talk
about priorities amongst priorities in government,
the issue that is most close at hand
tends to get the most attention.
The Arctic is a bit of a slow burn
issue and it's going to be there,
but if you don't act sooner rather than later,
you may find yourself closer to crisis, especially
with climate change and other impacts to the
indigenous communities or the region in general
because you didn't pay enough attention to it
now. Right now, a lot of our national attention
is focused on China-Taiwan, Russia-Ukraine.
We're only one another terrorism event from
refocusing on counterterrorism. And so, then
where does the Arctic fall? So I think it
requires attention. I think it requires some
advocacy. I think it requires some investment,
and that needs to be on a sustained basis instead
of episodic injects to make sure that we're ready,
postured to achieve those goals that are
in the National Arctic Strategy.
BRIMMER: It also should be remembered that
the Arctic in some ways is also part of a
national spirit. Living in the Arctic has had
an important cultural role for Canada, Russia,
and the Nordic countries. And I would suggest
that for the United States, one thing to think
about is to broaden our understanding of how
we think about the US in the world. We think
of the Transatlantic, Trans-Pacific, and the
Gulf. We think of our important neighbors to
the North in Canada. But even beyond that, the
United States is also an Arctic nation, so the
Arctic Ocean is America's fourth coast.
SIERRA: We live in an era of great power
competition, and part of that competition could
play out in a melting North pole. Caught in the
whirlwind are indigenous people and local
workers who depend on this changing region
for their livelihoods, and a wealth of flora
and fauna fighting to survive. Like space,
the Arctic is a region that we all wish could
forever remain peaceful. A shared territory for
scientific inquiry. But the oil beneath the waves,
and the perilous but valuable sea routes that are
opening up are a tempting prize that could
make that cooperation difficult to maintain.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes. If you ever have
any questions or suggestions or just want to chat,
email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org or hit us up
on Twitter at @CFR_org. Why It Matters is a
production of the Council on Foreign Relations.
The opinions expressed on the show are solely
that of the guests, not of CFR, which takes no
institutional positions on matters of policy.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria. Our associate podcast producer
is Molly McAnany. Our interns this semester are
Emily Pace and Rebecca Rottenberg. Robert
McMahon is our Managing Editor, and Doug
Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer. Extra help
for this episode was provided by Noah Berman,
Kali Robinson, and Jonathan Masters. Our
theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke, and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple
Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever
you get your audio. For Why It Matters, this is
Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See you around!